[Music]
thank you okay I'm going in just
hello what oh I'm so sorry
come here diabetes by the way such
an asshole
just promised me that neither of us will
ever die hello Myra just so you know I
will not be looking at your penis today
no it's not that
I've just been incredibly hungry I'm
starving I'm so thirsty drinking so much
never goes away but there's never a pig
more than I'm not it's just one constant
stream of urine duct tape my cos no
matter where it just keeps your ping
right now yeah I'm so tired I'm wildly
fatigued oh you don't have diabetes yes
I do I definitely have it
[Music]
well no having my mom cremated what do
you want me to say come over here I need
some cupcakes
I love you wouldn't be so hard to say
you just promise me when I die you
promised into whether settled carry
around 24/7 why would you die that paper
really so you just went through this
with your mom so now you know how to
take care of me I just can't believe my
time has come so soon I'm gonna go sit
down by the blood pressure machine
promise to walk me out when you're done
Jade dr. J I heard about your mother
she's dead yes I am so sorry to hear
that
thank you I know and now my earth to
what my wrath
I just last month I took a look at his
penis was there an accident how did he
done no no he has diabetes oh no please
he doesn't have diabetes now you should
see him he said no he's fine physically
he's fine
no you don't have diabetes
technically no but baby you're dying and
you just know I don't expect you to
understand just to wait on me hand and
foot until my final days
the duty would be
[Music]
the children a great
aha
but the new came my way don't stop
[Music]